The joe rogan experience is brought to
you by [inaudible] dot com if you go to
o,
n,
n I t get yourself some Alpha brain,
shroom tech sport,
shroom tech.
I'm Yoon.
What is all this stuff I'm talking
about?
These are all new tropics.
What does that mean?
Google it bitch.
Go to g,
O,
G,
l e entering all the information that
you're interested in getting because
need to find out what the fuck you're
putting in your body.
I tell people to Google Shit,
don't just buy our products.
This is what I'm saying.
What it is,
is their nutrients that are designed and
engineered to improve the way your brain
produces neurotransmitters.
It's a very complicated and a very
controversial subject,
but uh,
they do work.
There are a lot of clinical studies
there on,
on at.com you can find the references to
all the different things,
ingredients and what they've been proven
to do.
Uh,
I believe in it.
I believe in it so much that we have a
100% money back guarantee in the first
30 pills.
Nobody wants anybody to feel ripped off.
We're just trying to sell you good shit
that we use.
So if you're interested and you go to
[inaudible] dot com use the code name
Brogan,
save yourself 10% off.
But as I said,
if you have first started pills,
100% money back guarantee,
you don't even have to return it.
Just say,
this isn't for me,
and that's it,
or business has done,
but we,
uh,
we hope you will enjoy it and we hope
you'll,
uh,
it'll enhance your brain's son.
Also,
we have kettle bells and battle ropes.
These are the,
the newest additions to ana.com.
If you've never worked out with
kettlebells before,
don't get crazy and meathead,
you really don't need anything more than
a 35 pound kettle bell for the first
time.
And you're like,
Joe,
you don't even know me.
You don't even know how swole I am.
35 pounds.
The fuck am I going to do with that?
For Real,
there's a,
there's a video that I use called
extreme kettlebell cardio
workouts@dragondoor.com.
It's incredible.
15.
Yes,
I just start out with a 10.
You can do whatever the fuck you want.
I started off with the cat or you can go
crazy and prove me wrong and use a 50 if
you're a fucking savage.
But my point is it's not,
uh,
it's incredible workout.
Great for you,
and it's great for functional strength.
You know,
moving things,
picking things up.
Your whole body will work as one unit.
That is what kettlebells are designed
for.
All right.
You know what the fuck I'm talking
about.
Let's get the thing ruin.
Hit the hit the music.
Brian,
let's start this thing.
Which town?
Okay.
Hey,
Joe Rogan podcast.
We're joined today by the world's
coolest wine maker.
What's up brother?
I their first because I've never
actually met Brian.
Some kind of,
yeah,
he's a weird motherfucker.
Trust me.
Kind of make me nervous,
so I'm just going to get and make you
more nervous.
As time goes on.
As he's looking at me,
he's going to have a few comments that
are just getting my God dude,
just looking at me.
Look right at me.
He does.
Look at people.
It's,
he doesn't know the effect it has on
folks.
How the fuck do you go from being a rock
star to being a rock star slash wine
maker?
What was the,
it was just a whim.
Did you have this idea?
I think the biggest,
the biggest hurdle there you have to get
over is it,
I don't think I've ever really been a
rock.
I've actually dabbled in the rock star
stuff,
you know,
um,
Allah American psycho.
But uh,
for the most part it was just kind of me
putting it on.
I've always kind of been a small town
kid,
uh,
working in the garden.
So you think of yourself as just a human
being who likes to do things that are
interesting and this is what's
interesting to you.
You know,
I've done things over the years and just
get,
get inspired and do more things and then
all sudden accidentally over along the
way somewhere you,
you make a few dollars on something and
I just go home,
great.
Then I can do more stuff.
But even the way you did this is so
uniquely you,
you know,
you didn't,
you didn't do it in Sonoma county.
You didn't take an established orchard
orchard rather than in it,
you know,
and take over it.
You know,
you went to a weird place,
you went to fucking Arizona.
You know,
people think of Arizona,
you think of kidnappings and in Mexico,
and you know,
that's the thing.
You don't think of Nice tea.
Yeah.
You don't think of wine vineyards.
Uh,
well,
a historic
glee,
almost,
almost every state that could actually
sustain grapes,
uh,
vinifera.
So European grapes,
almost every state had vineyards and
Haley and prohibition just threw a
wrench,
stuck,
told him monkey wrench in that.
And we can go down the whole conspiracy
theory regarding,
uh,
prohibition.
Oh yeah.
Well,
it's a beautiful one.
Yeah.
It's real.
It's still working today with marijuana.
Yeah.
And same,
same people.
Right.
So it's,
so that pretty much what that did is it
just interrupted our appreciation for
what
wine,
uh,
as a,
as a daily part in Europe.
And that's why European wines became so
much more popular than American wines.
Right.
You know,
but they have,
they have
some places in Europe have had thousands
of years to develop what's going on on
there,
on that particular spot.
They've had like just decades and
centuries of notes,
uh,
whether on the terrain,
on the results,
on the process.
So they're so far ahead of us in terms
of just understanding those things and
it's part of their culture.
It's the ground and the soil and what
minerals and story with people who have
not had any experience with farming
might not know,
but they vary wildly from place to
place.
How do you find the right spot if it
hasn't had a vineyard there before?
Or do you just say,
this is a good spot?
Let's you know,
you,
you join the military,
you get out of the military,
you form a band,
take $1 million,
you go dump that million dollars into a
fucking black hole in the middle of
nowhere and then go,
well that was the wrong hole and you
move over here and you're digging
another hole.
How many times did you do?
Oh God.
Oh,
she did a few,
well,
there's a couple of sites.
It's just our working what we've tried.
So it's basically it to like,
um,
get a printer.
They can actually print money that looks
real and uh,
make sure you keep changing the
cartridges.
So did you have to buy new land
[inaudible] no,
you end up,
well,
I mean you just have to pick the right
variety for that spot.
So if you're pretty,
if you have
a pretty good idea that an area
consisting good grapes there that are
going to make,
you know,
uh,
the kind of wine you want to drink,
um,
then it's a matter of figuring out what
varietals going to work best there.
I mean,
we're not trying to grow,
we're not trying to grow wine and grow
grapes in,
in Alaska.
That's going to be hard.
You're going to have to really hard
pressed to find the right volume that
Alicia grow their,
uh,
you know,
we have Canadian ice wine.
You have like a lot of the American
hybrids to like vet all Blanca and
Norton and knows kind of grapes that
will grow in that extreme cold
temperatures.
Uh,
not a lot of daylight.
Um,
it's,
it really ripe in the Vinifera.
But in our area we have everything is
that everything's there,
everything's set up.
So it's just a matter of finding in that
particular location that you dumped all
your money into this land.
Like it figured out what grows there and
it's not going to be,
it's probably not going to be what you
think is going to grow.
There's going to be something else and
it's going to take a lot of trial and
error and you know,
$40,000 an acre to find out.
So you have to try different grapes and
then go through a full season and then
test the results.
Well,
you know,
it's,
it's more like a,
it's more like just looking at the soil
and uh,
and that and that particular terrain and
where it is and how it's oriented north,
south,
east,
west and then try to pick the right
grape for that site before you put
anything on the ground,
figure out what great might work there.
Now this is a natural resource process
for you.
Is it something that you knew about
already?
Because you were interested in it or did
you have to learn all this as you went
along and had to learn?
I learned the hard way.
So you know when you put the vine in the
ground you don't know for,
well you might,
if it comes,
you know,
if it sticks around the next year
within,
you know you're at least you've got that
part,
then you know I'd actually grew,
then you've got to figure it up.
It's going to get the point where you
can actually train it to start,
you know,
setting fruit on it.
So you're not going to see fruit on that
vine.
You can probably push it and get some
fruit on there the third year.
But if you really want quality fruit and
want to just let the plant really
sinking,
find its way,
get the root system to get the whole
structure of it a happy and healthy and
then set fruit on it on the fourth year.
And then you make the wine out of that
fruit in the fourth year and then get to
try it like in its fifth year.
So five years down the road after having
planted those vines,
you go,
well,
that wine sucks.
Oh Man,
what the fuck?
Yeah.
And there's no other way you can do
that.
There's no other like high tech DNA.
It's not necessarily determine lens,
right?
Yeah.
If you have,
if you have,
like if you're in California,
in Napa Valley and you've got a vineyard
over here and a vineyard over there,
chances are the vineyard right here in
the middle is probably going to do okay.
Then you'll know what to grow by,
what everyone around you is.
You have a history,
but we have no history.
You're,
you know,
you're guessing you're,
you're trying to make it work.
And we're finding now through trial and
error and you know,
many,
many dollars later,
we're finding that the Italian and
Spanish and varietals and southern Rhone
varietals are doing pretty well.
It,
what was the motivation to do this in
such,
you know,
sort of,
uh,
from the beginning manner,
you know,
I mean,
you,
you went at it about as his most
difficult path as possible to creating a
wa to creating a wine.
Um,
it's just,
it was where I lived and just having
traveled around the world,
seeing other regions that kind of
resembled those regions and uh,
I dunno,
I Kinda,
I'm the on the,
uh,
the contrarian,
you know,
say one thing.
I'm going to go the other way just to
balance things out.
So just looking at that place,
I just thought,
okay,
I have an idea.
You're looking off your back porch.
I'm looking at Atlanta.
I said,
I go,
okay.
Um,
this sounds like a,
I want to try this.
Cause how many other vineyards are in
Arizona?
Uh,
well there's,
there are now,
when I first started there was about 20,
maybe 18 bonded wineries.
Now there's about 50.
Wow.
You model yourself after them.
I would look at like what soil they're
using,
whether it's similar to yours.
Did you have like,
you know,
anything to go on?
Not really,
no.
I mean,
I had a guy from a UC Davis come out and
kind of chase his tail a little bit and
look at it and go,
luck.
Now,
do you have to treat the soil in any
way?
Do you have to mulch it or not
necessarily you and you have to make
some soil adjustments if,
if really needed.
But you know,
in a perfect world,
you don't do any of that.
He just let it be what it's going to be.
So,
because you want to really express that
place as much as you can and you want
to,
you want to help,
uh,
the mines along.
If there,
if there is some nutrient deficiencies
as you go,
you'll,
you'll notice right away in the vines,
um,
if you're paying attention,
but you can also test for it.
You know,
they did little petioles tat and like
the ends of the vine,
you'd send a man who just see what's in
them and what's not in them.
So there'll be able to tell you roughly
what kind of a wine it'll produce.
A No,
they'll just let you know whether the
plant is healthy.
Uh,
so what needs nutrients?
So,
whether or not,
I mean we could plant,
uh,
like I said,
we can plan American hybrids there and
they'll do great thrive look,
look awesome.
But the wine's crap.
You know,
you know,
uh,
wine made out of Norton this,
it's very rare that you have somebody
who will impress you with a glass of
Norton.
I don't even know what Norton is.
Manischewitz it's equivalent.
The first time I ever heard about an
area making things taste differently
was,
uh,
I had a friend who was really in Cuban
cigars.
Tommy,
you have this Vl,
oh,
I forget what the name of this one area
of tube is,
but it's a small area,
you know,
and it's,
it's a few hundred acres or something
like that.
And in that few hundred acres,
they produce all the worlds,
Cuban cigars,
and it's just whatever's in that soil,
just making it up that much about
cigars.
But I know I've had people hand me,
okay,
here's,
here's three different cigars,
um,
that have the little thing.
He repped off it and try them out.
You know who I liked that one Cuban.
It's amazing how strong they are.
It's amazing.
Like what it actually does to you.
Like it's a fucking drug.
Like if you have a good solid cigar,
like,
and you're like,
Whoa,
like I'm high right now.
This is a real,
yeah,
you get motivated to do things.
We had a guy in here yesterday,
Rob Wolf was a nutritionist.
She was telling us that,
uh,
creativity is enhanced by nicotine,
gum,
nicotine.
It's actually not bad for you.
It's bad for you is all the shit that's
in cigarettes.
Right.
But the nicotine itself actually,
you know,
so a positive drug,
just hard for us to wrap our heads
around.
So,
uh,
you,
you found this spot and how many years
did it take you to you producing what
you have here today?
You have two wines here today.
Yeah.
Um,
these,
uh,
this,
the,
the rosacea that I brought,
this is the Lelea Nebbiolo Rosé.
This is from our southern Arizona
Vineyard that we actually purchased.
It was an existing vineyard,
uh,
and,
Graham County area.
It's called Bonita springs been here.
So I've been,
you know,
with my,
cause I have,
well three,
three wineries,
a caduceus and American vineyards or are
my,
my label,
I make these wines.
And then Arizona stronghold is my sister
company and I'm an investor and Co
founder of that company.
And that company bought these two
existing vineyards.
Dennis Southern Arizona.
So there's the Arizona strong open,
your coachees county out and Wilcox and
then the Benita springs vineyard in
Graham County.
So this is most of your focus right now
is making wine.
When do you just very well when it,
when it comes to harvest time,
that's,
that's where I have to be.
Cause there's,
there's no other way around it.
It's,
that's,
you know,
my wife runs the lab and I make the
wine.
So when it's harvest time,
uh,
Monday,
so starting Monday you gather up the
grapes and then start the process of
turning them into wine.
So it's a,
it's,
it'll,
it'll go on through,
you know,
we'll see our first,
uh,
we'll see our first white's probably
around the first week of August.
So I had to basically be back there to
just get ready and getting everything
ready.
What is the process,
the fermentation process?
I know you gather up the wine or you
gather up the grapes,
rather you smash them and then what
happens?
Well,
it depends on,
depends on how you,
how you do it.
There's some,
there's some people that,
uh,
you do the harvest,
you bring them in and you actually
destem the grapes.
You put him into December and it's kind
of like a big tumbler and the grapes
fall through these holes and these
little paddles and knock the stems out
the end.
And then they'll fall into either a
crusher that just kind of pop them and
puts them into the bin.
And you now they're pumped them into a
tank or you put them in a bin and your
friend in that way,
or has it just stemmed,
you just leave them whole berry and
that's carbonic masturbation.
And so that's more like a peanut Anwar
process.
So the produce different results,
whether they have a stem or not.
Uh,
I think personally it might,
my choices,
I do all my wines,
all the reds.
I do them a carbonic masturbation with
the whole berry.
Um,
cause I feel like just in the results
when you crush him,
sometimes,
depending on the region,
uh,
the,
the skins and the stems and the seeds,
uh,
you know,
seeds and the seeds and skins mainly
when you crush them,
we actually have more exposure to those
kind of like negative tannins,
kind of like a green,
uh,
tannins and bitter that don't quite,
you know,
they don't necessarily precipitate out.
How did you get involved in all this?
Is this something you've always been
fascinated with or did you just one day
get into it and never looked back?
Um,
it's,
I think it's,
you know,
I grew up,
working in fruit orchards and my dad had
a garden and uh,
so I think it's just kind of,
I kind of fall into it a little bit,
you know,
reluctantly back then.
Of course you hate it.
You don't want to weed,
you know what to look for the cut or if
you don't want to like do all that
stuff.
But then when you look back on you
actually that was pretty,
that was pretty cool.
It's hands on,
you know,
when you see what's the food on your
table,
you know,
as a teenager you don't get it,
but later on you go.
We made that actually gets you from Ohio
originally.
Originally from Ohio.
Um,
I'm also from an io.
Awesome.
I'm also from Ohio also.
And so I also left.
He left to go to Michigan.
Ah,
I see what's going on.
And as a,
you know,
just as a thank you for letting me
leave,
but we gave you Detroit.
So Detroit is now in northern Ohio or I
welcome still alive.
That's sweet.
Bears are moving into Detroit.
So can we try some of this stuff?
No,
I mean,
yes to smell it.
Anything.
You can try it here.
I'll call you one of these.
Do you,
uh,
do you still do a lot of art?
Because I knew you went to college for
art and a lot of your,
your videos are very art based.
Uh,
do you personally do any arts still or
uh,
or were you really ever into doing it?
I think it was more like the director or
producer,
you know,
I was kind of into the coordinating of
getting artists in a room to do things.
But,
uh,
as far as the actual talent,
I can't,
I can't play piano.
I can't play guitar.
I can barely draw.
How did you become the lead singer of a
band then?
Accidentally I was the loudest asshole
in the room.
You were the most bold.
That was a guy who thought I had
something to say.
Well,
uh,
Doug,
your music man.
But of course like everybody,
but I really became a fan when I read
this piece that you wrote on Hixon
Gracie.
Why?
Uh,
you know,
you just,
you just nailed it.
Nailed the whole balance of the balance
article and yeah.
Yeah.
And Hixon himself was a fascinating guy.
Well,
he's a very few people that I've met
that you,
you meet him and like right away,
you know,
there's something different about this
cat.
And uh,
Hixon is incredibly intense guy.
That's,
it's so rare you find a real martial
arts master.
So sort of a cliche term that we,
uh,
you know,
we think of an,
terms of like movies.
The one man who is the master who has it
all in control.
Well,
not to take anything away from Hixson,
but I've actually learned more from
training with boiler boilers.
What amazing.
Yeah.
Boiler and uh,
Carlos Machado.
Uh,
cause we got to travel around.
I just,
I can't train consistently,
so I can't just walk into a Dojo and
just throw my gay and expect not to have
my ass handed to me and then not be able
to do the show.
Right,
right,
right.
So,
you know,
I was just do privates and I just do
them.
The guys who
are as old or older than me,
so they don't have anything to prove.
So it's just like,
hey,
let's just have some fun.
And,
uh,
I'd rather than trying to put a notch in
their belt with my blood,
well,
none of the older guys would do that
anyway.
The,
uh,
especially the,
I mean when you get to the black belt
level,
no one's trying to,
they're very cool about it.
But you know,
I can't just walk into a room and just
dive into a class.
Yeah.
Not at,
not at the age of 48 going on 50.
Did you used to do that?
Did you take classes
earlier on?
And that's how I got injured.
You walk into the wrong place that they
think for some reason you're,
you know,
challenging their manhood and all of a
sudden it's like,
dude,
I'm in.
At that point I only weighed like one
35.
So you're rolling into any,
any Dojo we're rolling into a year.
Like,
you know,
you might as well be somebody's child.
The real problem is that a blue belt,
purple belt stage where you're just
trying to get as many kills as you can.
And it's like anyone that comes in,
I'll look at this guy.
He's only 140 pounds.
So that's a kill.
I'm going to get this one.
I'm going,
it's not ignoring you.
I'm looking for the photo of boiler so I
can prove that I actually did that.
No,
I,
no idea.
I've seen here,
I've seen photos of you and Dave camp,
Mario and Bj Penn and I'm sure this
wine,
by the way,
it's delicious.
Yeah.
What kind is this?
What does this,
this is a Rosa,
Rosa and Nebbiolo.
There's,
there's my whole life.
I just saw him recently and he says one
of his fighters fought in the UFC a
couple of weeks ago.
I don't know if that will show up.
Nope.
I can see his hairline.
Incredible family.
I want to talk about a family that's had
an impact on martial arts.
Really,
it an amazing thing that in the 1990s
with all we thought we knew about
martial arts,
it's one family from Brazil can have
this monstrous impact.
And it's funny how like,
well now you know that.
And do you still see guys pimping there?
You know,
dance theater,
sort of much,
much more rare,
square dance,
much more rare than ever before.
You know,
there's,
there's still a few holdouts that are
teaching some silly form of something.
Had A,
I had a friend who was working with a
band and,
um,
he's,
you know,
a solid practitioner,
uh,
finally got his black belt.
Um,
and uh,
but he doesn't even,
he did security.
He's doing mainly a director of security
and for these different tours.
And this particular one,
you know,
he wasn't doing any martial arts.
I've just like doing his job and
directing what was going on.
And then one of the artists was flying
this guy in and paying them all this
money to do this Kung Fu stuff.
You know,
he's being respectful.
He's just letting that like,
and not my place to even insert into
that,
but like,
you know,
he's would always like to angle into
getting an opportunity on the road
because when you're traveling,
trying to train and try to do this stuff
is,
it's almost impossible.
It's really hard to do.
Um,
and so,
you know,
if there's any way he can work into at
least getting to train with them,
that'd be great.
So,
you know,
whenever the opportunity presented
itself,
he was like,
you know,
I,
I also would,
you know,
try not to do a Jujitsu.
The love to jump in with you guys at
some point is to get a workout in or
something.
And the guy basically said,
look,
if I'm,
you know,
it wasn't responding to him.
So he's like finally went,
look,
you know,
what we do is like,
university level that,
that Jujitsu thing is like kindergarten.
Some of my buddies like,
oh,
okay,
it's on.
So he calls,
he calls Hanzo and says,
Hanzo,
I'm on the east coast.
I need a place to go train.
And this is what happened in hands.
I was like,
what the bring them with a fucking come
from other fuck it down to the,
it was so amazing that like silicon,
all this guy is now,
he's kind of cornered,
he's into,
he's kind of basically challenged my
friend and my,
and my friends trying to be as
respectful as possible.
I'm just going to,
the guy just kept going and going about
with,
you know,
uh,
the,
just the disrespect talk.
That's how,
you know he sucks.
Most likely it was,
and there's a video online of the
schooling and it was a,
Oh,
really?
The video that's online is,
it's after like,
you know,
they started,
they did some stuff and it was over so
fast that finally handle it.
Kept going.
Okay,
now you can't,
you can't hit him.
You can't,
you can't tackle him.
You can't use your arm.
Like he kept like taking things away
from my guy,
still like to make it so that it was
just destroying.
Yeah.
And it was like,
just embarrassing.
So the guy who hasn't been paying this
guy,
this money this whole time is looking at
this going,
what the fuck have I been paying for?
Nonsense.
Yeah.
There's a lot of that out there were
dancing.
Well,
for the longest time,
that was the majority of martial arts
was fuckery.
You know,
I mean,
most of the schools you would find on
corners,
or my friend,
my friend Eddie had a guy that he was
taking can food from and the guy went to
China to learn secret techniques under
this deadly master.
And then he found the guy's supposed to
be in China.
He found his fucking car at the
supermarket parking lot.
He found the guy in the suit like get
the fuck man.
I thought you were in China.
Oh yeah.
I mean I'm on my way to trips kind of
town.
I was going to Chinatown.
It's uh,
you know,
it was secret.
It was a hustle for a long time.
All you had to do was pretend you just
had to like throw some techniques that
you learned from,
I mean you could watch a John Claude van
Damme movie,
kind of get a good idea how he's moving
his body and sort of recreate that.
And if you are really crazy,
next thing you know,
you could have a school where you're
teaching your own style of self defense.
That's completely ineffective.
I want to do when it's like a,
it's,
you know,
practical fighting where you're
actually,
you know,
you're going to be in a bar so you might
as well be drunk.
So we called it dear son dough and you
just show up and immediately kind a six
pack and then we start.
That's a good idea,
right?
We've got to throw your chair away.
I know it's dead.
I think lunch you grab one of these
other ones that don't get used as much.
Don't squeak as much.
Yeah.
Um,
I thought that was his back.
No,
but imagine if it was,
that would be a,
that would be one of the worst feelings
ever.
If you dedicated a massive amount of
your life to some bullshit and then it's
just exposed in front of you like that
right now.
It happens to a lot of martial artists,
man.
I've met a lot of people who,
you know,
whether it was taekwondo or whatever,
traditional martial art that had a giant
hole in it and they didn't even realize
that.
Well,
it's the same with my friend.
He was like,
he was a black belt,
I think,
taekwondo and he will,
he rolled into a,
uh,
Rodrigo Bodgie his place in Saint Louis
and went,
okay,
you know,
whatever this is,
let me just show you.
And he just had his ass handed to him
like repeatedly.
Anyone.
Okay.
I'm sold.
Yeah.
It was a black belt in taekwondo before
ever did.
You did so.
And when I first did Jujitsu,
there was this kid that I'll never
forget this purple belt kid my age,
my size is nothing special about him.
And he's just maul me.
Every class he would maul me.
It was like I was a baby.
Like I couldn't do anything to him.
I couldn't defend myself.
I'd be exhausted.
You just fucking strangle me and I have
to tap.
It was just so humiliating and humbling.
You know?
I remember thinking,
Wow,
I was walking around,
not even knowing somebody my size could
do that to me.
I have no idea.
Really had no idea.
So living in a completely delusional
world of martial arts,
proudness.
Well,
we have to remember that we,
the reason that we're a hair at all is
at some point during our human
development,
we,
you know,
instinctively and just accidentally
realized that we can't rely on our
strength or speed.
We had to rely on our brain.
So cause it,
you know,
we don't just run out and grab the line
and rip its head off.
We either run from it and find a stick
and sharpen it and you know,
go out in teams and you know,
take down the elephant with five guys,
you know,
so that you know,
so when you think of martial arts in
that manner,
you start to realize how important the
mental game is as opposed to just the
physical game.
Well,
especially in Jujitsu,
it's one of the rare martial arts were
technique is really the most important
aspect of,
of,
of the practice.
And when you get a really big strong
guy,
it's actually a disadvantage for a
strong guy to learn Jujitsu because the
best technical guides are always small,
weaker guys cause they have to be
technical.
Then there's nothing they can muscle or
force.
Whereas the big guys,
they can get away with some sloppy shit
because of the fact that they're big and
strong.
So they're really hindering themselves
by using strength.
I mean that's,
there's no sport like that and no
martial art even like that.
I mean technique is very important.
And kickboxing,
but athleticism and speed is equally
important.
You know,
if you're,
if you're very technical but slow,
it really won't work.
And the Jujitsu,
these guys,
the,
the saddest thing about rolling with
someone like a Hixon or as John John
Machado,
it's like they don't even try.
Like,
it's not like they're straining and
moving hardly to slowly,
oh my friend.
Oh,
you're on your back again.
you better protect this arm because this
is the one,
nine,
eight and seven.
You're like,
what's he going to do?
And then he does it and you go,
okay,
Hixon would do that to black belts who
would pick an arm and tell them,
I'm going to get your right arm in an
arm bar.
And you're like,
there's no fucking way.
I'm just kidding.
Does it want to chicken my in this
mother fucker arms over there?
Like how are you going to get me in an
arm bar?
And all of a sudden he's over there and
you're tapping out.
Yeah,
it's,
I didn't know that there was something
like that before.
And when you,
once you understand like how technical
Jujitsu is,
it really become so fascinating.
Josh Waitzkin is a,
a famous chess player.
He was the movie searching for Bobby
Fisher was based on him and he sort of
got disillusioned with Chaz after a
while I got bored with it and devoted
the same energy to Jujitsu and he's one
of Marcella Garcia,
his proteges now.
And he has,
I think it's called a m m g J and
Marcella Garcia Jujitsu inaction Mgj and
action.com.
And um,
it's maybe Mgj Jay.
Um,
and it's,
um,
the,
the website,
he has it broken down the way you would
break down chess.
Like he breaks down moves and as
different,
you know,
different transitions,
different moves.
So you can look at it,
you know,
and much more may be analytical and you
know,
a calculated move,
move way.
And then you would,
if you were just over,
his name is Josh Waitzkin.
Okay.
Yeah,
there's the guy that,
or the trains out of a Hen's Oh,
studio in New York.
I think his name's John.
John Donahoe maybe.
Yeah,
he's a beast.
And it's just like,
it's,
it's like,
it's like the chest.
He wants his brain going,
okay,
this is,
this is this millimeter.
A philosophy student.
He was a university student and it was
bouncing.
That's what he was doing for fun,
you know,
or to to pay bills.
And along the way someone said,
hey,
she alerts and Jujitsu and he became
completely obsessed,
sleeps on the mats.
I mean literally teach us all day.
I mean don heard is a legend in Jujitsu
circles.
He's a suit.
It's what happens when a super
intelligent guy gets physically absorbed
in a sport.
Yeah.
He's just,
uh,
he's,
he works with a lot of top guys.
Like he's always in a George Saint
Pierre is corner,
he's a,
there's a lot of good guys that come out
of his jam and there's guys who give
good instruction and this guys who suck
in the corner and the corner is some
guys who just,
you listened to them and I have to do
everything I can and not criticize them
and get the fuck are you saying or that
guy like this is nonsense.
Like you don't,
you're better off saying nothing because
you're,
you're putting in like an air of despair
and idiocy into this,
into this cage.
They say such stupid shit,
but not Donna,
her man,
Donna.
Hers like Super Precise.
You need to hold your left hand slightly
higher.
Your Chin talked shoulders up,
move to your right side.
If he's throwing the left first doc on
de,
then go for a single.
The single does not work.
You transitioned to a double have water,
three deep breath and you're like,
Whoa,
this motherfucker just got schooled.
You know,
you hear him talk and you know,
this guy knows exactly what I'm supposed
to do.
If I could just listen to this guy,
I think I'm going to be okay.
It's a crazy world.
The world of intelligence and,
and risk and martial art and that's what
w you know,
people like for the wrong reasons.
Associate martial arts and especially
associate competition with meatheads
assholes,
dummies.
But the most brilliant minds and some of
the most interesting people that I've
ever met when martial arts
practitioners,
because there's a certain amount of
calculation you have to do.
While under extreme duress and pressure
and there's a risk involved.
The risk is like physical health and all
those together created an incredible
ward.
When you're successful in the reward is
amazing.
But the downside is like mad for most
people that the down is too low and they
avoid it.
And that's the people that can,
can make their way through those waters.
The,
the strongest salmon who get up that
waterfall to me,
some of the most interesting people that
I've ever met.
Yup.
I would have to agree.
Yeah.
And that's what I got out of your
article.
I was like,
this guy gets it.
He's,
you're,
you're seeing the essence of a,
of what this is all about.
How long have you been doing Jujitsu
now?
Uh,
I started in the mid to late nineties.
I got injured right around 2000 and I
have only done it,
you know,
on and off now whenever I can,
when you're,
when you're doing your wines,
it must be like 16 hours a day.
My must be.
Uh,
well,
you know,
I'm pretty,
I'm pretty organized so I,
you know,
I make sure that whatever I can,
whatever I can bring to the table as far
as making things easier and smoother and
not getting in my own way,
like just a lot of logistics and
understanding.
Like if I do this,
I'm going to have to undo this and five
moves.
So I always like,
I've laid things out in a manner that,
you know,
I'm in the winery around 6:00 AM six 30
but I'm wrapping it up around eight
o'clock.
So you're a black belt in winemaking,
sweating,
trying to say I'm a black building
logistics,
blackbelt logistics,
just understanding the process and not
getting in my own way.
And then when you go from that mode into
musician mode,
do you just do it on based on your
schedule?
Like whenever your time becomes free,
you go,
okay.
You know,
starting in
it's October or whatever,
a little bit more emotion,
a little bit more,
a random this with that.
With that,
you know,
you kind of have to kind of ride those
waves a little bit.
But in a way,
when you have enough time under your
belt,
you can kind of force the situation.
You can,
you know,
a lot of times I just get in my,
my truck and I got a decent stereo on
the truck and I got the tracks and I
just,
that way nobody can mess with me.
I can't get a phone call and they'll be
knocking on the door.
I just go park somewhere and turn the
music up.
But the notepad and start writing,
cause nobody now you're in your world.
If he might,
if I'm in my house,
you know the phone's going to ring.
I'm going to check my email,
I'm going to try to ask a question.
Or you know,
males in,
you know,
oh it's that super troopers on HBO
again.
So much for writing.
Yeah.
That's why.
Right when everyone's asleep.
I don't,
don't even start until 11:00 PM 12:00 PM
everyone in my house
asleep.
I liked it when people around me are
asleep too.
I'd like
to think the neighbors are sleep.
I like to think that I'm not picking up
any weird vibes from anybody.
Everybody's in Z zone.
Right.
You know?
But do you,
um,
when you,
when you write,
do you have like specific times where
you set aside time to write?
He just try to do it whenever the
creative whim,
whim,
you know,
just kind of do it,
it'll be like focused periods of time.
Like I'm at this week is going to be
dedicated to any,
and same thing with training.
If I'm at a train or if I'm at,
I'd be doing Jujitsu,
I'm going to do any of that stuff.
I will hire somebody to be there because
now I have to do it.
Right.
So if I have friends that were,
you know,
musician friends,
they flown out,
we're going to write this week,
okay,
I'm in my truck,
I'm over here and want to come in and
we're going to track some stuff that
didn't work back to the truck.
Why Arizona?
That's where I live.
Just always lived there.
I moved there in [inaudible] 95.
Really?
Why 95 I hate La.
Hate your town.
Let's not mine,
but I don't like it either.
And tried to escape,
moved here and basically December of 89,
so,
you know,
basically 1,990 January.
And uh,
it just,
it only took a little bit of time.
I mean,
I got,
don't get me wrong,
I got a lot out of this town.
Things,
you know,
odd things happen for me.
Um,
you're just kind of set the ball in
motion.
I mean there's,
you know,
I was doing a lot of things,
we'll buy life before I moved to La.
Um,
and there's a lot of achievements and
things that I'd,
that I'd kind of done for myself.
And,
uh,
but then it wasn't until I was actually
in la in a band where somebody who's
profiting on my decision making that you
actually heard about me.
So,
you know,
there's a lot of things that I was kind
of doing before I got here.
And then I fell into the band thing and
that kind of got popular.
And,
uh,
that was my actually stuck here for as
long as I did.
Cause I just within like a couple of
years,
I was like,
this is not for me.
I don't,
I need to be in a small town.
When it got to a certain point,
have the fame of tool,
you could pretty much have done whatever
you want to anyway because you're mostly
just touring and you just had to be
around the people when you were
rehearsing and preparing.
Right.
Kind of.
Yeah.
I think a little bit more hands on than
that,
but,
uh,
you know,
for the most part,
uh,
that was,
that was the case.
But,
you know,
and then been been from 95 to 2000.
I kind of bounced back and forth a
little bit from Arizona to here just
because of the work.
You know,
you have to,
when you're recording and doing stuff,
he had to kind of be there for Nda.
Right.
You're on the road for pretty much.
And that in those days it was easily six
months out of the year,
a year traveling.
But of course,
you're younger than you can handle it.
Now.
The area you're out,
it's like,
that's like a haunted wild west town,
right?
It's an old,
it's an old copper mining town.
Uh,
it's like a billion dollar copper mine.
It had this huge or body underneath this
side of this hill,
$1 billion worth of copper.
And that was like,
you know,
1920s,
1930s billions.
So it was like,
it was a huge or body,
like big enough to put a cathedral in
the hole in the ground that they took
all the copper up.
And did you pick this area because it
just seemed like an area or you don't
really like the vibe of it?
No,
I am at,
I had a dream.
I was supposed to be out of fucking la.
He got it.
Yeah.
And I just kept having this recurring
dream and it's like a,
you know,
it was a very specific images and place.
And uh,
I think,
you know,
for some reason I thought it was Arizona
and a,
I remember talking to Hicks about it and
I go on,
I think,
I think it was supposed to be in
Arizona.
And uh,
I mentioned that to Tim Alexander and
you know,
I said,
I've been to Phoenix,
I'm not,
I'm not having it.
Um,
and I described the dream and Tim went,
oh,
I know what that is.
See Cause he's from,
he's from Arizona.
And so he went,
okay,
I have to take you some place.
We drove up there and like rolling into
that valley just going,
Holy Shit,
this is the place.
Wow.
And then I got up to the town,
it's like,
no shit.
Do you interact with the town's folks?
Because to me that's the hardest thing
about moving to anywhere.
It's,
you've got to find cool people,
you know,
in the,
I am the absolute troublemaker in that
time.
It comes in,
you know,
they,
it's uh,
it was an old mining town.
It kind of,
they kind of turned,
a lot of that went away.
It's like 20,000 people in this town at
one point.
And we'd have working the mind like,
and then the Clarkdale area and to
Cottonwood area and draw Mary work in
his mind,
you know,
when,
uh,
want to dry it up and you know,
there was the depression and the World
War One and doing all that kind of
stuff.
It kind of shut down.
It dropped down to like,
you know,
30 people in this small town.
Whoa.
And then of course,
you know,
the 70,
60,
70,
so the draft Dodgers and the people that
just wanted to do what they wanted to
do,
uh,
moved into this basically in abandoned
town.
You,
anyone new Bisbee no.
Uh,
I'm sure we're Bisbee is,
but it's not,
I think it's more on the,
on the edge of the state and somewhere
it's very weird,
but a very similar,
very similar scenario.
So you know,
the trust fund babies and the hippies
moved in,
kind of took over the town and uh,
there for them,
you know,
for the most part,
the people that moved into the town are
not the kind of people that built the
town,
not the kind of visionary as it came in
and went,
I think there's copper under this thing
and then did all this stuff.
I'm more like those people.
And so I'm kind of the enemy because I
do stuff,
you know,
heaven forbid.
Um,
so how you a trouble maker and the town
though,
anyone,
they don't,
you know,
they fear change.
And you know,
we came here to retire and then not do
anything.
Well you make too much noise or too
strange.
I just stuff I'm just doing stuff,
bringing by,
you know,
by discovering the terroir there and
making wine there.
I'm bringing people to town.
You're what you're bringing people on.
We went on to new people in town.
So you're telling how they going to pay
for your pipes in your electric and how
are going to make your streets be safe.
It's a municipality,
not a camping ground.
You need,
he need funding.
You need tax dollars to fix your thing.
And you know,
the best way to really fix your town is
if you have something that's unique to
your town and export,
if you will.
I found it.
How dare I?
So you're doing well for the town and
they just don't like anything moving or
anyone to make them feel.
There's a handful of people that are
like the hand.
basically,
they're their mos.
You just lay in the street and if you
can move them,
okay,
then you can kind of go down the street.
But if you can't move them and you give
up,
they win and you just kind of sail tail
between your legs and you leave.
I don't,
I don't know how to move stuff.
That's my problem with La is that La is
where my friends are and if I had to
move to another place,
I'd have to deal with a bunch of fucking
people and all their nonsense,
you know,
unless you bring everybody with you,
which is also going to start a
complicated.
Yeah,
get all Kuresh on it.
Do you have friends out in Jerome?
Yeah,
absolutely.
Did you have them already?
You know,
Amy,
I made a lot of friends,
just some really,
really awesome artists in that town,
like really good people.
And they all mean well that,
don't get me wrong,
all of every single person in the talent
means well,
and they're all good people.
But you know,
that's just personalities and small town
politics,
but still better than the insane buzz of
this hive this fall.
Yeah,
30 million.
Hi.
I much prefer the conflict that we have
with our,
with our people and in Jerome over
whatever the hell it was.
It went over there on the five and the
third one 34 today.
Hey,
we just decided to shut this ramp down.
Well,
have you ever flown in to lax and you
see the four oh five and you see
literally seven eight nine 10 miles of
stopped cars and you crawl into your
overhead Bin and hope that they just let
you go back to Tokyo is like,
what the fuck is that?
This is craziness.
This is just,
we're just banking on nothing going
wrong ever in a place where the earth
moves.
Yeah.
Yet here I am like an idiot.
I'm trying to get out.
I'm,
I'm working on right now.
I'm working on my next move any minute
now.
I tried Colorado for a little bit.
It's a long story,
but my dog got eaten by a mountain lion.
I came back.
Yeah.
Colorado is a weird,
when like you go to Denver and there's
that area where almost everybody's
missing an eye and arm or in a
wheelchair or a walker.
That's like a weird,
like,
like a twin peaks.
But like on steroids area and you kind
of go,
we have,
we'd have contests like okay,
we're here for 24 hours,
whoever can count the most wheelchairs
and,
and you know,
three points for a wheelchair.
One point for like a missing arm and be
people coming back to like,
you know,
the soundcheck going,
I got 40 points.
Really?
What area of Denver is this?
It's right on that 16th street promenade
area right there in no sin in the center
of town there.
It's insane.
It's,
you're,
you're there for,
if you're there for longer than 12
hours,
start going,
what's going on?
Is there like a,
you know,
they,
they testing out these things.
Are they,
are these people actually in them?
I've never noticed.
I picked Denver because it's got a
strong medical marijuana community.
And then so once you get used to,
the way they have it set up in La is you
can't deal with the nonsense of dealing
with drug dealers.
It's just become so stupid.
But Denver set up pretty much exactly
like Ella is Denver in boulder.
There's places everywhere.
They have a,
I think they call it broad stir.
Damn.
When they have one area where it's
a,
I think it's Broadway,
there was this like,
you know,
bakery shops and you know,
the whole deal.
It's got a good,
they have to like a sensible liberal
vibe.
You know,
Denver in a Boulder's a little bit more
radical,
but Denver has a sensible openminded
vibe.
Like they support guns and they support
hunting and they support outdoors
activities,
but they're also in favor of gay
marriage and they're also in favor of
not discriminating.
And you know,
so it's,
it's a very interesting,
that's why I picked it,
but Arizona always scared me,
man.
It's,
it's definitely a scary place when,
in terms of
all those things you just mentioned.
But I think it's,
I think all that stuff's kinda changing
there because you can't have something
that's so far one way and not have a
pushback and have and have and have a
community that's just the complete polar
opposite.
And it's absolutely there.
So eventually it'll just kind of come
around.
The,
the idea of living in cities,
I think it's one day not going to be
necessary anymore.
I think we needed it because everybody
had to be on top everybody.
Cause that's where you worked and you
know,
in order to communicate with everybody.
But now because of the Internet,
I think,
uh,
there's a lot of people's jobs that
don't have to be in,
in the swarm.
Yeah.
I mean there's a lot of,
there's definitely a lot of just change
in general happening with the,
just the way we think about stuff.
And,
um,
I don't know about you,
but I've had like a had a week there
about two months ago or it's just,
everything just seemed like the
gyroscopes were off and I couldn't,
I couldn't get anything right.
It was like I'd forgotten how to do the
most simple things,
you know,
like,
not,
not the perfect example.
I got to walk outside to change a tire
and I've got like a carrot and a candle.
Like,
okay,
well
one lane,
there was a cycle,
like a vibe or I think,
I think it's,
I still kind of feel a little bit,
yeah.
But I was like,
I was,
I kind of called a friend who,
uh,
she's,
you know,
she's as crazy as I am.
It really,
she's like,
uh,
she does a complete Kundalini Yoga.
You,
unless she wakes up at 4:00 AM to watch
the sunrise and do the breath of fire.
And so she's,
you know,
how the,
she's a complete Kook and I'm an,
I drank the Koolaid or,
or we're onto something here.
But,
uh,
you know,
she,
she said just being a funny,
you should ask that because that's kind
of what we're,
what she's seeing in her world,
how everything's done,
you know,
the gyroscopes or just kind of off and
uh,
and the biggest,
I think the biggest thing she was
suggesting and has kind of done some
reading on it as well,
is like,
it's just more a matter of paying
attention.
I'm not letting it get to you,
uh,
not being like all,
you know,
Tony Robbins and get all,
positive greeny guy,
but,
uh,
you know,
just like know that it's all gonna work
out and don't let the petty shit get you
down.
Don't let the,
the dark stuff sink in because it's
almost like you're in a record groove,
you're in the light groove,
and if you let,
if you've flop over to the dark groove,
you kind of get stuck in that groove and
it's kind of a downward spiral.
So one thing that I've found it's most
difficult to deal with when you deal
with a large city or a large as you are,
you're constantly getting other people's
energy in there.
It's sometimes hard to dictate your own
path.
And that's what she was saying
because I think in a way you have to
kind of just not hang out on a fear.
Just kind of settle in calmly and just
like we're talking about what the
Jujitsu,
the guy,
he's big and he's strong and he's got
technique,
but you just had to take a deep breath
and some level know that one way or
another it's all gonna work out as
Kundalini Yoga people are fascinating.
A buddy of mine has a friend that does
the same thing
every morning.
She does the breath of fire and she
claims to achieve psychedelic states.
She says that,
uh,
because of all her years of practice,
she,
it's just like as if she's taking heavy
drugs,
she goes to other worlds and
communicates with entities and you know,
and has,
what she describes is indescribable
experiences.
She said,
if I told you what I could do just with
my own breath exercises and couldn't
Daleney Yoga,
you wouldn't believe me.
Right.
And you know,
most of my friends that are in into that
stuff,
into that deep,
they don't talk about it just because
it's such an individual experience.
And uh,
and I had another friend who I'm going
to similar,
a similar path and you know,
she kind of grew up in the,
in the 60 was everybody's doing,
you know,
doing acid and stuff.
And uh,
she had mentioned that,
you know,
it was Kinda,
it was cool for the,
the jumpstart for people to kind of get
into that consciousness and be thinking
on that level.
But at the same time,
they didn't really do the work to get
there.
So they really didn't understand what it
was they were experiencing.
So when away she called it spiritual
theft,
but you got like,
and all of a sudden you're just right in
the middle of this thing,
but you don't really have any business
being there.
Right.
You can't really process what it is that
you're experiencing.
Recreational mushroom trips.
Yeah.
And so,
yeah,
it's so you're like,
here you are.
And then,
you know,
for most people that just,
that's lights out for them.
They're going to be a little mark the
rest of their lives.
But I kind of agree with that.
I think that some of the work taking
that time and really taking your time,
getting to those states are in just in
your life in general and doing anything.
Um,
but it's,
it's really difficult for most people
these days because they want what they
want when they want it because they're
so used to getting whatever the fuck it
is they want when they want it to.
They don't get it.
They lose their shit.
Yeah.
Which is exactly opposite of the
psychedelic experience.
What it would teach you.
I think,
um,
the,
the approach is so important and doing
the work and saying,
doing the work is so important because
you're treating whatever this experience
is,
is going to be with a,
a deep amount of respect.
And unless you do that,
you know,
I don't think you're,
you're really going to get the most out
of it.
I mean,
if you just go into it and try to just,
uh,
let it cure you or let it figure you out
or let it,
you're just going to be too blown away
with the whole thing to really absorb
any of it.
Right.
You're doing the work.
And like,
one of the things that I really
appreciated about the people that really
get into Kundalini Yoga is they all seem
legit.
I haven't met anybody who claims the
psychedelic states who,
who doesn't really like a humble person.
It really seemed like there,
there's never any weird ego shit or you
know,
weird,
a trace of bullshit.
It's,
it seems like this,
this is just what they do.
And they'll tell,
talk to you about it and they'll
describe it to you.
But they say it's not about the,
it's not about the psychedelic state of
it.
It's all about just like a sort of a,
a,
it's about knowing that it's going to go
in knowing that it's all gonna work out.
Yeah.
You know,
and we might not even be included in
this form that we're in and how it's
gonna work out.
And if you can let go of the fear of
worrying about whether that's going to
happen or not.
As soon as you can just let go of that
fear and just,
you know,
let go.
Just appreciate what is,
appreciate what it is.
Don't worry about what Ken,
what would,
what may appreciate what is and know
that even if it doesn't work out,
it's going to work out cause it's all
works out even if it doesn't work out.
Exactly.
It's too hard for us to wrap our heads
around how big the whole picture is.
You know,
when you realize that,
you know,
what is the,
um,
the,
the Woodstock song,
we are stardust.
We are golden.
We are billion year old carbon.
Well we're,
we really are fucking Joni Mitchell.
Yeah.
Joni Mitchell,
who was the Crosby stills they covered
is what it was.
That's her song.
Yeah.
Brilliant Song.
And it's so true.
This is the thing that people don't
understand.
Human beings actually made because the
star Burns out,
explodes.
And it has to happen.
If it doesn't happen,
you don't make those materials and human
life,
carbon based life forms don't,
don't,
don't exist.
So even if it doesn't work out,
it works out right.
It doesn't,
you know,
you can understand in are in the state
that we're in and you know,
this
real tactical,
tactical,
uh,
existence that we live,
you know,
you get caught up with the game,
you kind of get into the fear.
Yeah.
Uh,
and uh,
that's part of it.
Super easy.
So it's okay.
You know,
but every now and he'd get kind of
wrapped up in it.
And,
uh,
I remember like last week,
the same guide to do Jitsu guy that I
was telling you about,
Todd,
he,
uh,
he's,
he just out of the blue texted me like,
so man,
how's it going?
Like,
it's almost like intuition.
how's it going?
Like,
funny you should ask,
it's been a shit storm the whole week.
And he goes,
Oh,
well let me just give you this.
And he sent me this,
I hope I brought it,
you send this thing.
I ended up forwarding it to a bunch of
people because I knew a bunch of other
people were going through some weird
shit and uh,
may I sure polluted
so live your life that the fear of death
can never enter your heart trouble.
No one about their religion,
respect others in their view and demand
that they respect yours.
I love your life.
Perfect your life,
beautify all things in your life.
Seek to make your life long and its
purpose in the service of your people.
Prepare a noble death song for the day.
When you go over to the great divide,
always give a word or a sign of salute
when meeting up or passing a friend,
even a stranger when an a lonely place.
Show respect to all people and grovel to
none when you arrived in the morning and
give thanks for the food,
for the joy of
living.
If you see no reason for giving thanks.
The fault lies only in yourself.
Uh,
abused.
No one and no thing for abuse turns the
wise ones into fools.
And Rob's a spirit of its division.
When it comes your time to die being out
like those whose hearts are filled with
fear and death so that their time comes,
they weep,
they pray for more,
a little time and live their lives again
over and over in a different way.
Instead sing near death song and die
like a hero going home.
That's fucking beautiful.
Like,
so of course all my friends are like,
you know who wrote that?
So I had to go back to him and go,
where'd you get that?
He goes,
uh,
homeless do gave it to me.
Wow.
It's Jesus.
It's like,
please don't say it's l,
Ron Hubbard.
I would be my luck like Adolf Hitler.
Well it sounds like I,
I actually,
it's uh,
I actually found it online and it's
uh,
chief Tecumseh crouching tiger from the,
from the shiny nation.
Whoa.
He died in 18,
13.
Wow.
That makes it even
more cool.
Cause I thought it was some new age
douchebag,
probably pilfered some stuff off the
internet and pieced it together.
No,
that's perfect.
Yeah,
I agree with everything you said.
Except for Megan.
Front of religion.
You go,
girl.
Other than that it's got me,
I think religion has to be made fun of
it
because
if you can't make fun of things that are
ridiculous,
you're missing out on a big part of
what's fun about this life and
religions.
Ridiculous respect it,
but made fun of it,
right?
Yeah.
Other than that,
I'm down town with the Shawnee warriors.
He had thought that was great that he,
you know,
he says some homeless dude while we
lost,
we lost such a massive chunk of what
those people had learned about living
this life of nomadic life,
of following animals and you know,
following,
following herds of buffalo around and,
and learning about the connection
between,
I mean,
you gotta think about the,
the,
the deep respect native Americans had
for the animals that they killed.
And you know,
it's,
it's such a,
an interesting way of life.
They,
they kept up for so long while most of
the Western world had already moved on
to,
you know,
riding horses and Kingdoms and houses
and agriculture and these people were
just traveling around and living off the
land.
It says so much wisdom we could have
learned from those people and it was
wiped out.
It's a,
it's,
it's a weird time too when you think
about that.
Just that was just a couple of hundred
years ago,
a blip in human civilization and there
was these nomadic people,
you know,
living in this area.
I remember watching a,
I went to movies with my son is a few
years ago and it was that a black
stallion movie.
It's,
you know,
some animation.
I mean,
and it was pretty,
I'm just kind of sitting in the theater,
just kind of,
it kind of dawned on me and I'm kind of
like,
I'm like the,
the curmudgeon with his son.
Like,
you know,
my kid just going,
can you just enjoy the movie please?
But I'm looking at it going,
this whole movie is based on this
exhilarating feeling of like this black
horse and this guy kind of stopping the
white man for moving west.
And it's like,
but I'm watching the fucking movie in
Los
and my son's just like,
will you let it go and just enjoy this
movie and get me more popcorn?
Please.
Yeah.
It's like you rude against us.
I mean,
that's what Avatar is.
Yeah.
I mean,
avatars don't think they're coming back.
Yeah.
That was the first shit.
UNOBTAINIUM billions of dollars,
I think obtaining them ever coming back.
I mean,
that was the Santa Maria,
right?
Our ship.
That was the beginning of the first wave
of the fuckers
until I tried the other stuff.
What do you,
what is your,
this is the,
this is the Shinola.
I'm really a red wine guy.
I love that.
Rosa.
It's delicious.
This is a,
this is a special
drop.
Um,
we had,
we got hit with Frost really hard and,
uh,
early 2011,
so we didn't have a lot of Arizona fruit
in our vineyards to work with.
So I panicked and I,
uh,
is this one yours here?
We,
yeah.
And I sourced some fruit from right over
the border from our,
our vineyards right down on the,
on the border,
uh,
on the 10 as you're heading toward New
Mexico,
it's in Wilcox in that area.
So right over that border,
like another hour or so,
just pass.
Wilcox is a New Mexico vineyard and this
guy's out there,
great grower.
He's got all these fantastic Italian
varietals growing there and there.
You know,
there's a historic,
it's a pretty old vineyard there.
So I picked these all these grapes up
for,
uh,
not much.
And uh,
did this blend.
It's Sangiovese.
They'd dual Choate over phospho and
premed Tivo.
So it's a straight up the Italian blend.
It's delicious from New Mexico grapes.
And it's,
what do you call it?
Shinola.
Come on.
Cause that your own name.
Yeah.
Oh No.
What?
I mean,
you know,
it's the,
is that a type of wine?
It's actual type of wine.
It's a,
it's a reference to the jerk.
The shit from Shinola.
Yep.
Okay.
Yeah.
Wow.
Recognize?
Um,
yeah,
New Mexico is a,
a fascinating area.
You know,
I think,
uh,
that's where it,
val Kilmer went and grew his head.
That's where I was watching magical
space.
I was watching the ghost and the
darkness the other day and I was like,
there's a funny fucking Internet meme
where it's Val Kilmer at is most
bloated.
And it says,
remember when I was Batman,
lol,
Val Kilmer moved to to,
uh,
New Mexico and just bought a ranch and
just grew his head.
I don't know what the fuck happened,
but in this ghost and the darkness,
I'm like,
Jesus Christ.
I was a handsome man.
It was stunning.
And we just decided,
you know what,
I'm,
I like pills better.
I'm just new.
Moved to New Mexico,
that movie a couple years ago with,
uh,
Robert Downey Jr.
Yeah.
Well it was that crazy movie.
He's struck a little.
Yeah,
he's trying,
he's got it under control.
Yeah.
It seems like you realize,
fuck,
am I doing,
I kinda liked it.
Yeah.
It was a fun movie.
I don't remember what it was though.
What the hell was it called?
Some sort of a,
and involve letters.
Yeah.
And range and in a certain order and I
can't remember any of them.
Yeah.
They all get blurry after a while.
Um,
you became buddies with one of my
biggest influences in one of my biggest
idols is Hicks.
How did you,
uh,
how'd you meet him?
How did that
go down?
Uh,
well,
you know,
as a,
as,
as you do,
you kind of just,
somebody can hand you a cassette back in
the day.
It's,
it's a cassette.
It's a,
it's a tape recording and it goes around
and around,
um,
uh,
you know,
right around the same time as a eight
tracks,
but he got the cassette of one is to
first,
uh,
releases and uh,
on the,
on the road just like absorbing all this
stuff.
And an eventually we,
uh,
when we put out another record,
we basically thanked him on it and,
uh,
send them a copy of the record and he
reached out and then we just kind of hit
it off and we hit on all these plans.
This was back,
you know,
earlier,
earlier tool days.
So,
um,
you know,
we had all these plans that we wanted to
kind of do something with him.
And,
uh,
we were,
you know,
we were still kind of a young bands.
This is like 93,
94 and,
uh,
we were going to do a tour together and
then he got sick.
That kind of allow,
you know,
plans right out the window,
kind of suck at.
Right.
When the time was,
we were small enough to where we could
still,
we could actually do a comedy tour,
you know,
with a comedian and a rock band.
Uh,
as soon as it was,
you know,
a year later there was,
things kind of blew up a little bit and
it would have been,
yeah.
I mean,
for example,
we played several shows in the
California area where a tenacious d
opened for us,
but we were big enough band where people
in the honors,
she's like,
get this shit off the stage.
I like throwing shit at them.
When we had the,
we've had like David Cross and Greg
Behrendt do stuff in front of our,
uh,
a show to open the thing and just
getting pelted with stuff now,
you know,
that wouldn't happen now because they
know who they are,
but
it was still happening.
Yeah.
I know.
People are brutal,
man.
Yeah.